bienvenue à l'université de bourgogne le
message à bosse à fisher en grand avec
parcours super les futurs étudiants se
demandaient si la fac elle et leur
ouvrir les bras
aujourd'hui il ne resterait plus qu'une
poignée de personnes sans affectation
et pour ceux qui arpentent déjà le
campus l'été s'est avéré plus ou moins
stressante
moi j'étais prêt du premier coup j'ai eu
la chance mais j'ai des copains compas
et et qui ont été pris que vers juillet
tous et pour les appartements et c'est
un peu compliqué j'ai quitté la prépa
pour revenir en dut en première année et
bat gémit quand même jour de trois mois
pour trouver mon truc alors que bon
j'avais je pense à un niveau acceptable
pour le d t + 9 % d'étudiants cette
rentrée dont une forte hausse de
première année l'université de bourgogne
est attractive tant mieux se réjouit son
président mais cela signifie aussi
pousser les murs des places
supplémentaires ont été ouvertes
notamment en staps psycho ou droit nous
avions voté une capacité d'accueil
globalement sur l'établissement en
hausse de 250 par rapport à l'année
passée et au jour d'aujourd'hui nous
sommes déjà à environ 440 étudiants en
plus
reste à savoir sur quels critères les
étudiants ont été pris dans telle ou
telle filière
les jeunes interrogés ce matin ne le
savait pas exactement parfois allait-il
juste une intuition je vais pas dossier
terrible t et finalement j'ai pu y avoir
accès bah grâce g à côté de ça des
petites expériences professionnelles qui
au fait que ça dure ça doit être un
point positif pour mon parcours c'est
justement on regarde pas simplement les
notes bien sûr parce que ça n'a qu'une
valeur très indicative mais donc encore
une fois tous les commentaires qui
pouvait être fait par les enseignants du
secondaire sur la motivation des élèves
sur leur persévérance sur la capacité à
travailler aussi en autonomie conclusion
tout le monde ou presque a obtenu une
place mais les étudiants ont-ils accéder
à la formation de leurs rêves
cette question reste aujourd'hui sans
réponse reconnaît l'université